Windows has a number of different ways
to configure new network connections.
One of the easiest is through the
control panel. You can choose network
and sharing center and set up a new
connection or network. From there, you
can select to connect to the internet,
set up a new network, or connect to a
workplace. There are also similar
options under the Windows settings and
network and internet category. This
connection setup page provides a wizard
that takes you through all of the
settings that you need to input for that
particular network type. And there are
many different network types. You can
connect directly to the network with
Ethernet. You can set up a VPN
connection, a dialup connection, and
more. VPN stands for virtual private
network, and it's a way to communicate
through a public network using
encryption to protect all of your data.
For example, you might have a corporate
network which has file servers and
printers and other resources. And you
might be at a coffee shop. Obviously,
the network inside of your corporate
network is very secure, but the network
at the coffee shop is effectively wide
open for everybody. To be sure that we
can keep all of our data protected
through the network, we're going to
encrypt all of this communication that
we're sending back and forth to our
laptop. We do this by configuring a VPN
client. That client software is running
on our laptop and it's encrypting all of
the communication that's going through
the network and ending up at a VPN
concentrator that's managed by your
corporate network. The concentrator
takes all of that encrypted data,
decrypts it, and sends it to the
resources inside of your corporate
network. to be able to send a response
back to your laptop. The process repeats
by encrypting all of the data on the
concentrator, sending it across the
network and sending it finally to your
laptop where it is decrypted for your
local use. The VPN concentrator that
you're using may require a separate set
of software that you would install onto
your laptop, but Windows also includes a
built-in VPN client that might also
apply. You would find that under the
setup connection or network dialogue box
and choose to connect to a workplace
which allows you to set up a dialup or a
VPN connection. If you select the option
to connect to a workplace, it will ask
you if you'd like to use your internet
connection, which is a VPN, or a dialup
line. In this case, we're going to
connect to a VPN connection. It then
asks for an internet address of the VPN
concentrator. In this example, it's
VPN.ample.com. and you can give it a
name of VPN connection. You can choose
to use a smart card with this that adds
additional authentication to the VPN
communication. You can remember your
credentials and then you can allow other
people to use this connection as well.
The smart card integration is additional
multiffactor authentication. This might
include something you know, which is
your password, something you have, which
would be your smart card, and if you're
integrating any type of biometrics, such
as a fingerprint, it would be something
you are. We would then click the create
button. And if we wanted to connect to
this VPN, we can enable and disable it
from the network status icon that's in
the system tray of your Windows
desktop. On most wireless connections,
we simply select the wireless network
we'd like to connect to and then provide
the appropriate password. But there are
other configuration settings that might
apply, especially if you're in a
business. For example, you might need to
specify the name of the wireless network
or the SSID. That refers to the service
set identification and that's
effectively the name of the wireless
network. You would then choose the
security type that is used on that
wireless network. And this is the type
of encryption that will be used over
this wireless connection. We would also
include an encryption type. On older
wireless networks, we used to use TKIP,
but most wireless networks you connect
to these days will be AES. And then
lastly, we would include any security
key information. If this is a local
network at home, then you'll probably
have WPA2 or WPA3, and you would have a
personal connection, which uses a PSK or
a pre-shared key. If you're in an
enterprise, then you're using a
centralized authentication, which is the
same WPA2 or WPA3, but it is in an
enterprise configuration that uses a
type of authentication known as
802.1x. This authentication type will
connect to a central authentication
server to check your centralized
username and password so that you can
use the same username that you use for
everything else in your organization.
Wired connections are relatively
straightforward. You plug an Ethernet
cable into the back of your computer and
you connect that to the rest of your
network. That direct connection is
usually the fastest. And in the world of
Windows networking, the fastest
connection is always the default
connection. So, if you're connected
simultaneously to an Ethernet network, a
wireless network, and a wireless wide
area network, it's more than likely that
your Ethernet network is the fastest,
which means it will be the default
connection. To set specific
configuration parameters of the wired
network, we can right mouse click on the
Ethernet adapter and choose the option
for properties. All of the properties
allow you to change configuration of the
adapter, the Microsoft networking
settings, and in this case, we're going
to select the TCP IP version 4 settings.
If we choose the properties of that
link, we can apply a manual IP address
or we can specify to obtain an IP
address automatically from a DHCP
server. We can also receive DNS server
addresses automatically from the DHCP
server, or we can manually add them
ourself. And if you'd like to add a
separate configuration just in case the
DHCP server is not available, we would
add that under the tab for alternate
configuration where you can specify an
automatic private IP address or APIPA or
you can manually configure the IP
address settings in this window. If you
then connect to the network and DHCP is
not available, it will use all of the
settings that you've configured in the
alternate configuration tab.
Another type of connectivity is using
the cellular networks that we normally
associate with our smartphones and our
tablets. This is referred to as a
wireless wide area network or a WWAN
connection. This could use a physical
network interface card like this
hardware adapter that we see on our
screen or it may be something that we're
plugging into a USB interface. You might
also connect to a wireless wide area
network using your smartphone. You can
connect via a tethered connection or use
your smartphone as a hotspot to be able
to gain access to the internet. If
you're using a hardware adapter, either
one that's built internal to your system
or one that you plug into USB, it might
require thirdparty software to connect
to the network. So, make sure you check
the documentation of your device to
confirm that you have all of the
software that corresponds to the
hardware that you're using.
Proxy servers sit on your network as an
intermediate device between you and the
rest of the network. This is often used
as a security tool to protect you from
the internet. Because the proxy server
is sitting in the middle of the
conversation, it can send requests on
your behalf, receive the answer to those
requests, confirm that the answer is
legitimate and something that won't harm
your computer, and then send you the
response from that request. You can
configure these proxy settings in your
control panel under internet options,
connections, and LAN settings. Or you
can go to your Windows settings and
choose the option for network and
internet and proxy. Inside of the proxy
options, you can configure your proxy
setup to happen automatically or you can
specify a proxy server and the
appropriate authentication for that
server. You can also define exceptions
to this proxy because some applications
will not work properly when
communicating through a proxied
connection. This allows you to specify
the application that will ignore all of
these proxy settings and communicate
directly to the internet. When you're
configuring network configurations and
security settings inside of Windows, it
will often define a network profile that
will be associated with those settings.
The network profile defines a very broad
range of networks that you might connect
to and it defines configurations
differently depending on where you're
plugging into the network. For example,
if you're at home or if you're at work,
you're on a private network. This
usually means it's a very safe network.
There's often a firewall that's
providing security to the rest of the
internet and it's commonly seen if
you're connecting at home or you're
connecting at work. If you're out at a
coffee shop, you're at a hotel, or
you're somewhere where there is an open
Wi-Fi connection, then you would define
that as a public network. The default
configuration for a public connection
means that we will not provide any file
sharing. You won't allow any inbound
connectivity to your computer, and this
provides the highest level of security
inside of Windows. But of course, you
can customize all of these settings to
provide more or less security on either
of these network profiles. And you might
even find additional network profiles on
your computer to provide even more
granular control of
security. In a previous video, we showed
you how you can connect to a network
share at the command line of your
Windows computer, but you can do this
also from the file explorer that's built
into Windows. You simply need the name
of the server and the name of the share
on that server, and you can associate
that with a local drive letter on your
computer. We often refer to this as
mapping a drive letter in your Windows
configuration. And that means that you
can connect to that share. But instead
of specifying the server name and the
share name every time you wanted to
connect to that device, you can simply
refer to it as drive S, drive U, drive
H, or some other drive letter. Just as
you can connect to a share, you can just
as easily disconnect from the share. If
you right mouse click on any of these
network shares, you have the option to
disconnect from that share inside of
File
Explorer. The process of mapping a drive
inside of File Explorer is very easy.
You can see that I have a number of
drives that are already connected, but I
do not have an H drive currently
connected on the network. So, we'd like
to map a new drive letter using that
letter H. When you connect to the share,
it will check your authentication, and
if it doesn't apply to that share,
you'll need to provide the correct
authentication before it will connect.
Depending on the version of Windows that
you're using, you can choose the option
to map a network drive from the top
toolbar or click the three dots and
choose the option to map a network
drive. This will bring up a dialogue box
that allows you to specify what drive
letter you would like to use. It lists
all of the available drive letters, and
in our case, we'll choose drive letter
H. And then we can specify the folder
that we'd like to connect to. In this
particular case, the share name is gate
room and it's on server deadl. To be
able to specify this, we use two
backslashes and the name of the server.
So in this case, it will be backslash
back slash deadless and then a backslash
and the name of the share. And in this
case, that share is called gate room.
Once we have that configuration set, we
can finish our connection. And you'll
see that driveh now appears in our file
explorer. And of course, you can do all
of this at the command line by using the
net use command. You specify the name of
the drive letter you'd like to use. In
this case, it's H colon. And then you
would use back slashback slash deadless
back/gate room. And because there is a
space in that share name, we would put
quotes around that entire
destination. There may be times when
you're connected to a network where you
are charged based on how much of that
network you're using. In that case, you
may want to change your Windows
configuration to use a metered
connection. That will reduce the data
usage over the network and ultimately
cost you less money to use the network.
Under our Windows settings, I'm in the
network and internet option. And I'm
going to choose the option for Ethernet.
Inside of that Ethernet setting is a
toggle switch for metered connection.
And by simply turning that on, we are
now performing network metering. If you
want to control more details around that
network metering, you can click the set
a data limit to help control data usage
on this network. This will bring up a
different screen that shows all of the
usage statistics for the applications
you're currently using. And then you can
click an option to enter a limit, which
might be a monthly limit, a one-time
limit, or an unlimited type of
connection. You can specify when this
limit resets and what the data limit
should be for all network communication
over that connection.